[Applause]
anyway this might be the last one before
society sort of like concertinas because
they're coronavirus what a great concert
upstairs to the brain why have you
started with this many come up with it
actually needlessly complicated one but
yeah this could be when we're all in
solve self-isolation watching this this
could be the last bit you know new
content yeah it could be make people
could be watching you from the bunker
this could be it you know and then and
then when futures societies that rebuild
after the Mad Max dystopia der
coronavirus will definitely be and we're
not getting slightly over and then this
will be at though judge culture by what
we say in this next hour well that's a
lot of pressure on this episode actually
I was thinking back to the last time we
had you on the show and I remember just
to think how much has changed it's been
less than a year my opening question I
think to you was your working class
story what's that all about
well I think we see as I Spit on you
with my corona sorry that's what people
normally do anyway just to say I love
the fact that wall hyper were we're now
saliva you know we wouldn't even mention
were for mention now you like see it in
slow motion what I see on the train
coming down it like those people coffin
and they look you know like in those
Alien films where where there's some
sort of contagion and one person on the
ship has got it but they're trying to
hide it yes they've got boils coming out
on their skin
yeah now I was I was in the stage of a
day in in Bromsgrove and I had a couple
of coughs come up just as you do
naturally but the stakes for for
suppressing it felt so high do you not
mean I've cause like there's the you
know it's all several thousand people in
from these are bring what's interesting
rise if this ban comes in and they say
right Liz there's a ban on kind of
gatherings over 500 people then it will
really show where people are at in their
sort of torreón yeah cuz I go are we
fine I am comfortably yes
become that successful yeah I'm
unsuccessful enough to deal with the
girl smashing it hey I saw you sign
about like I'm trying to make a serious
point but that's gone out of the window
with Corona but my point was my British
kind of like blitz ok good this is for
now is this how you close a show jet
that is gonna be in tonight I just have
like a little mask on yeah I'm opening
for Jeff tonight so he's gonna be me him
and three people who still done yeah I
mean if the audience are really coughing
you might be doing the whole show the
door you know those outfits you getting
in et when the when the fellas arrived
yeah that'll be I'll come out stage on
that you know for now I'm I think what I
have is I was think about this yesterday
ISM I have something this applies to
politics and it does apply to your point
is I have a mixture of optimism and
apathy where I I believe everything
could be all right in the end in almost
every situation but that's also slightly
born of the fact that I am true I'm a
pathetic enough to know I can't change
things and in this situation where you
can't change things you might as well be
optimistic yeah if you're not going to
do anything to change things you there's
no point getting upset about something
that you're not going to actively try
and orchestrate a different outcome so
I'm going to call their optimism
[Music]